[Musik]
hargesheim in rheinland pfalz ein
kleiner ort aus dem große summen
geflossen sein sollen
fast 130.000 euro aus der provinz für
wahlkämpfe von fdp politikern
[Musik]
afg chef jörg merten hat laut dieser
liste im wahlkampf profitiert rund
90.000 euro für plakate und flyer viele
geldgeber dafür sollen aus hargesheim
und umgebung kommen auch für afd
landtagskandidat kinoreihe aus essen
gibt es eine liste wahlkampfhilfe für
knapp 45.000 euro ein drittel des geldes
soros habe sein kommen
der kreisverband von fdp-fraktionschefin
alois weigl bekam 130.000 euro laut
liste sollen bürger rund um hargesheim
86.000 euro gespendet haben über eine
firma
[Musik]
warum gibt es gerade hier angeblich so
viele großzügige afd unterstützer wir
suchen die vermeintlichen geldgeber eine
betreibt ein nagelstudio blog listen hat
sie 15.000 euro quittiert darüber reden
sie nicht eine verwandte von ihr soll
angeblich sogar 25.000 euro gezahlt
haben für afd wahlkämpfe als wir sie
besuchen bleibt ihre haustür
verschlossen
das schweigen könnte gründe haben die
parteien forscherin soviel schönenberger
beschäftigt sich seit jahren mit dem
finanzgebaren der afg namen hergegeben
haben und das gemacht haben damit es im
rechenschaftsbericht dann so ausgeführt
wird dann kann es tatsächlich sein dass
sie sich entsprechend strafbar gemacht
haben wenden sich die betroffenen
personen tatsächlich strafbar gemacht
haben droht ihnen bis zu drei jahren
freiheitsstrafe oder eine geldstrafe
wir telefonieren die listen up
runterfahren mal stimmt einnahme nicht
mal ist eine anschrift falsch mehrere
der angeblichen spender behaupten
gegenüber frontal21 und korrektiv sie
wüssten nicht wie ihren namen auf die
liste kamen wegen dubioser
wahlkampfhilfe für die afg ermitteln
mehrere staatsanwaltschaften die
parteiführung bestreitet fehlverhalten
was ich ihnen sagen kann und das
wirklich rein und guten gewissens ich
habe nichts unrechtes getan ich habe
nichts illegales getan ich habe auch zu
keinem zeitpunkt die unwahrheit gesagt
oder global feststeht meutereien und
weidl wurden im wahlkampf massiv
unterstützt über zwei schweizer firmen
die eine die schweizer goal ag
sie finanzierte wahlkampagnen für morton
und reihe
das wertet die bundestagsverwaltung als
illegal spricht im falle reihe von einer
strohmann konstellation und verhängte
strafen von rund 400.000 euro
die afg klagt dagegen dürfen weil sie
aus der schweiz geflossen ist das heißt
dass die fdp hätte machen müssen wäre in
dem moment wo das geld aus der schweiz
auf ihrem konto dann mit nachzufragen ob
es wirklich aus dem vermögen dieser
dieser gmbh kommt oder von irgendwo
anders
und hier kommt hargesheim ins spiel zwei
familien aus der gegend stehen auf den
listen sollen die afg unterstützt haben
vor ort trafen wir einen mann dessen
name auf mehreren listen steht er
erzählt er und seiner bekannten hätten
tatsächlich gar kein geld gezahlt
sondern nur ihre unterschriften gegeben
gegen bezahlung er will nicht erkannt
werden
ich wurde angesprochen von einem
bekannten ob wir uns ein bisschen geld
dazu verdienen wollen mit der
unterschrift für eine spendenquittung
dann wurden uns 1000 euro zugesagt auf
der quittung stand die person für die
die spende ist das war mal eine spende
für seinen wahlkreis
der mann behauptet außerdem die
quittungen für afg chef mieten seien um
monate zurück datiert worden
also das datum war deutlich weiter
zurück bei den leuten quittung dieser
tag wo ich unterschrieben habe
im falle wollten wurden die 1000 euro
auch gezahlt
die ard stellt es anders da die
hargesheimer und weitere eu bürger seien
keine spender sondern sogenannte kosten
übernehme die hätten geld an die
schweizer firmen gegeben ohne wissen der
afd
über anwälte lässt die afg mitteilen es
gab und gibt keine absprachen
vereinbarungen verträge oder sonstige
abmachungen mit beziehungsweise zwischen
der goal ag und unserer mandantin
insbesondere nicht über eine
unterstützung in wahlkämpfen oder zu
nachträglichen vorgängen die angeblichen
listen
der kreisverband von fdp-fraktionschefin
weidl bekam allerdings direkt geld von
einer schweizer pharmafirma die
politikerin fand das völlig in ordnung
die afg behauptet das geld für wedels
wahlkampf sei zwar von der schweizer
firma überwiesen wurden stamm aber von
deutschen unter anderem wieder aus hage
sein
doch der zeuge sagt er und seine
bekannten hätten für weidl gar nicht
gespendet sondern nur quittungen
unterschrieben
das war ein halbes dreivierteljahr
später an die frau weiter spende für
wahlkreis auch baden württemberg
die staatsanwaltschaft konstanz
ermittelt wegen verstoßes gegen das
parteiengesetz
der partei drohen im spenden fall weil
ebenfalls fast 400.000 euro strafe
spanien costa brava hier lebt ein mann
der auch aus der nähe von hargesheim
stammt und auf allen drei listen steht
er soll die unterschriften gegen honorar
organisiert haben
wir versuchen mit ihm zu sprechen wollen
fragen in wessen auftrag er handelte
doch der mann geht nicht ans telefon
wegen der ungeklärten geldflüsse droht
afg chef molten ärger beim kommenden
parteitag ein antrag richtet sich gegen
die verantwortlichen der umstrittenen
wahlkampf hilfen aus der schweiz
wer vorsätzlich durch schuldhaftes
finanzgebaren die partei zu
strafzahlungen zwingt muss persönlich
dafür haften
diesen antrag unterstützt ein
einflussreicher afd funktionär aus
nordrhein westfalen sollten persönliche
verfehlungen festgestellt werden
ist die erwartungshaltung auch da dass
dann diese person auch dafür
geradestehen gab das ist meine feste
überzeugung und wie gesagt das
entspricht auch dem antrag und jeder
davon aus dass auch eine große anzahl
aus nrw diesen antrag unterstützen wird
bleibt auch dabei dass er meiner meinung
nach eine große unterstützung auf dem
parteitag an sich bekommen wird
die ard wird ihre spenden affäre nicht
los nicht den hargesheim und anderswo
die suche nach den wahren geldgebern
geht weiter
[Musik]